thanks to kiwico for supporting this
episode
of journey to the microcosmos click the
link in the description to learn more
and for a special offer
the paramecium is the consummate model
organism
it's a protozoan that is both easy to
grow
and easy to study which means that
microbiologists
have been able to learn all sorts of
secrets about eukaryotic life by
watching them
he might even call the paramecium a hero
in our pursuit of knowledge but just as
heroes and stories have enemies
the paramecium has its own foe and it is
this strange critter
no not the big eggplant-shaped looking
thing the smaller one
the one that looks a bit like a swimming
okra
this is didenium though it wasn't always
called that
when otto friedrich mueller first
described it in 1786 he thought he was
observing
a vorticella and so he named it
vorticella naciota
almost a century later samuel friedrich
stein
would change its name to didenium like
its paramecium foil the didnium
is assiliate but at first glance it
doesn't seem like it should be much of a
problem
for one thing paramecium can just get so
much
larger than a didenium plus the tidinium
is
just weird looking in fact between the
paramecium and the didnium the didnium
is the one that actually looks like
food we compared it to an okra earlier
but at other times
it looks more like a stretched out acorn
and the pointier bit
looks like a jalapeno stem of course
it is not a stem it is the didenium's
proboscis
which means that is the front of the
organism
and there's still plenty of weird to go
the didenium
has a long macronucleus that curves into
a sort of figure eight
shape and circling the organism's body
are two rows of cilia
called pectinells that seem almost
randomly placed
one row sits at the border of the
proboscis and the rest of the body
while the other clinches the middle like
a loose belt
it's a little bit tough to see the
pectinells in their
full fringy glory with our microscope
they look more like
four bundles of hair on the sides of the
didenium but you can see what it looks
like better in this illustration
and those cilia give didnium both its
very fast and very strange movement
when the didenium moves it really moves
but not necessarily in a way that seems
obvious to us at first glance
just trying to follow it with a camera
feels a little stressful
the first time james found one it
slipped so quickly in and out of view
that he barely caught a glimpse
he had to switch to a lower
magnification so he could zoom out and
see it
but for the didenium this seemingly out
of control movement is
very deliberate it's constantly rotating
in a clockwise fashion
but also leaning towards one side
so that it's moving in a spiral path
in the early 20th century scientists
added
ink to jelly just so they could slow the
didenium down
and follow this path the microbes
seemingly aimless trajectory helps the
didenium
cover a wide range of space in a short
amount of time
think of it compared to another skilled
hunter we watched recently
the lacrimaria olor which sends its neck
out into all directions to maximize the
odds of
encountering something the divinium is
doing something similar
but instead of extending its neck it's
sending its whole body into different
directions
and that speed is a big reason why
didium is so
effective as it zips around the
microcosmos
it will bump into things that don't
happen to be food and when it does
it politely backs up and moves on
but if it's proboscis makes contact with
something
edible then the didenium goes to work
seizing its prey with its proboscis
paralyzing it
and then eating it and while it's known
to consume other organisms what didium
really
really likes to eat are paramecium
it doesn't matter that a paramecium
might be
six times its size the didenium
is here for a meal and it will gladly
expand itself around the paramecium to
swallow it
but as you can see this is not a smooth
process the tidinium is still moving and
bumping around as it consumes the
paramusium and for a while
it's hard to even tell where the
predator ends and the prey begins
the only real didenium-like thing about
it is the spiral path it still takes as
it eats
and eats and eats but eventually
it settles back into its more awkward
looking self
so incredible is the didenium's appetite
that scientists have observed it eating
a pair of dividing paramecium
they've also occasionally been observed
exploding from eating too much
so there aren't hazards to this
lifestyle
but while the didenium is extremely
talented at hunting paramecium
and also capable of hunting other
organisms
it's actually pretty bad in some of its
other conquests
when didn't even try to eat rotifers
they are stymied
by the relatively tough exterior and
other ciliates like stenters are
too large and too tough and too active
for the dyodonium to do much damage to
and paired with its favorite prey the
didenium
is its own model system in the early
20th century
mathematicians came up with equations to
describe
how populations of predators and prey
oscillate
in response to each other more predators
means less prey which then means fewer
predators and more prey
lather rinse and repeat and you get a
cycle
that shapes relationships between
species in many different
environments and in attempting to see if
they could recreate these equations that
were
for the macroscopic world in a
microscopic environment
scientists and labs turned to paramecium
and identium to act
as a model predator prey system it
turned
out to be not so straightforward to
mimic nature in the lab
when scientists first started watching
didenium and paramecium in a flask the
didenium would inevitably consume the
paramecium
to extinction in turn driving
their own deaths it was only by building
on these experiments and finding ways to
adjust the interactions between predator
and prey
that they could reconstruct the
oscillations we expect
in nature of course that doesn't mean
they directly copied what nature does
how could they with an experimental
design meant to strip
many of the confounding elements of
ecology from their observations
but their work still provided insights
into how
organisms interact it's like a story
incapable of holding the vast entirety
of existence and yet still very useful
in its narrowness that the consummate
model organism has
such a consummate model predator then is
quite fortunate for us
even if for the microcosmos it's just
another story
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you again to
kiwiko
for supporting this episode kiwiko
creates
super cool hands-on projects for kids
that make learning
fun with the kiwico subscription each
month
the kid in your life will receive a fun
engaging new project which will help
develop their creativity
and confidence they have eight
subscription lines each catering to
different
age groups and topics and each box is
designed by experts and tested with kids
in their eureka crate intended for ages
14 and up
you can get this two in one lantern kit
that lets you construct
a camping lantern that also transforms
into a flashlight
so if you want to give a gift that keeps
the fun
and learning going all year long a kiwi
co subscription
delivers steam discovery long after the
holiday decorations are put away
so head on over to kiwico.com journey50
and use the code journey50 or click the
link in the description for 50
off your first month of any crate
and thank you as always to our patrons
all of you people on the screen right
now you're the people
that keep this show happening if you
want to become one of those people and
support this show
you can go to patreon.com journey2micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james
check out jam and germs on instagram
and if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby